The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: So I'm
ready for anything, hope I am.
Questions about any topic.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: I feel this
is like a White House press
conference.
I think there's always
somebody in the front row who
gets to ask the first
question, and then
gets to say thank you
Mr. President at the end,
and then I'm off.
Yes.
I'm tempted by the
way to ask you all,
are you going to
vote next Tuesday
and of course I'd like
to know who you vote for,
and I'd like to
give you my advice.
But I don't know
that that's proper.
If anybody wants
advice, they can email.
But please vote.
Please vote.
Yeah.
Alright, question here and
then we'll have, well, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Oh, OK,
so those were just posted.
Like, I see.
3.3 number two.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK, so this
was a case -- yeah, right.
Oh, OK.
We could be wrong so
this is 3.3 number two,
asks you about the flow field.
Which has no flow
in the x direction,
the velocity in the
x direction is zero.
The velocity in the
y direction is x.
OK, so suppose we just
take that as a full field
and try to understand,
is it a gradient?
I mean, so what are the
questions I would ask?
Is it a gradient of anything?
Because we're now thinking v and
w are pretty much the same guy.
So is it a gradient, yes or no?
If so, what's the potential?
Is it divergence-free,
yes or no?
If it is, what's
the stream function?
And of course if the answer
to both tests was yes, then
we would be talking
about Laplace's equation.
I suspect for this
example the answer,
at least to one of the
two questions, will be no.
So we won't have the two pieces
coming together into Laplace.
OK, so first of all.
Is it a gradient?
What's the test for, so
my two questions are,
is v the gradient of some u?
And what's the test for that?
You remember if it
is a gradient --
and see if I can
remember myself.
If it is a gradient, then this
is du/dx, and this is du/dy,
and the condition that v_1
and v_2 would have to satisfy
is that the y
derivative of that would
have to equal the x
derivative of that,
because on the right-hand
side they are the same.
u_xy is the same as u_yx.
So I would look at -- so
let me write that again.
I need dv_1/dy to equal dv_2/dx,
and is that true in this
example?
What's dv_1/dy?
Zero.
What's dv_2/dx?
One.
So the answer's no.
OK.
So, test failed.
Alright, the second question
is does it possibly sit over
in the divergence-free world?
Is the divergence of, now
I'll call it w. equal zero?
So the answer was
no to that question
but now I think the answer
to this question will be yes.
Because what's the
divergence of this thing?
It's the x derivative of
that, which is certainly
zero, plus the y derivative of
that, which is certainly zero.
So the answer is yes.
So there's no potential but
there is a stream function,
right?
Because the stream function
comes in with this test.
So let's remember what, just
from today's lecture, what
was the stream function?
From dw_1/dx+dw_2/dy=0, that'll
be satisfied if w_1 is the y
derivative of the
stream function,
and w_2 is minus
the x derivative.
Because then this matches
the x derivative of this
plus the y derivative of
this, which is the divergence;
on the right-hand
side I would get zero.
So there's got to be
an s, and what is it?
Probably not hard to find.
Let's see.
Here w_1 is zero,
so that tells me
s doesn't depend
on y at all. w_2
is x, so x is supposed to
be minus the x derivative
of the stream function, so what
is the stream function now?
Have I got room to put it here?
Just about.
What will work?
So again, here's w_1.
The y derivative of s
is zero. w_2 tells me
that the x derivative
of s is minus x.
So all I'm looking for is a
function that only depends
on x, has no dependence
on y, and its derivative
should be minus x.
So what's the function?
Minus a half of x squared.
Yeah, so this gives me s equal
minus a half of x squared.
Alright, so you're
saying that, so there
is a stream function, right.
And what does that travel along?
That travels along steam, that
means that the flow buzzes
along streamlines.
And what are the streamlines?
They're the lines
where s is constant.
Equipotentials were the
lines where u is constant,
but here we don't have
a u in this problem.
Streamlines are lines
where the s is constant,
so minus 1/2 x
squared is constant,
what's the picture look like?
Picture then, for
that, well, and you
know what the flow is doing
at a typical point here.
Say x=3, y=1.
Let me draw the little arrow.
With a big chalk Which
way is the flow going?
Well, the x component is
zero, the y component is x.
So the flow is going
up there, right?
Here the y component's x.
This whole line is all traveling
up with the same velocity.
If I drop a leaf there, it
buzzes up that straight line.
So that's the streamline.
And its velocity is,
that's x equal -- if, say,
the velocity is three
then this speed is three.
It's going up that line.
So that's a streamline.
And sure enough, on that
line minus 1/2 x squared
is a constant.
So you see we're not
talking parabolas
here because our curve is not
y equals minus 1/2 x squared,
it's minus 1/2 x
squared equal constant.
Yeah, that's what we want.
So, but now having got so
far, let me take x=1, say.
What's the flow like on that?
So there's a streamline
with s equal constant.
And the velocity
on that is zero,
so nothing is going in
that -- horizontally.
And now it's one, so the
flow is slower up this line.
OK, slower flow.
This was faster flow.
And then the question that's
in that homework problem is,
is there any rotation
in this flow?
We think about rotation, we have
an image of rotational flow.
And that could be the next
example, we could figure out.
A flow that goes around
in circles, right?
Those would be the streamlines.
So this would be like pure
rotation, shall I call it.
But I don't have that there.
I just want to draw the
other picture, in which
the streamlines are circles.
To have another nice,
clean, beautiful example.
OK, but here we don't have.
Our streamlines
are straight lines,
and yet we have rotation.
That's the point here.
Why do I say we have rotation?
Because the test for rotation
was that original test
of looking at, which I just
wrote the answer to be no here.
So if it's not a
gradient, the reason
is there's some rotation.
Gradient fields don't
have any rotation.
The rotation is this
thing that comes out,
yeah it's this
difference. dv_2/dx,
it's the difference
between those that tells us
the rotation.
And that was not zero, right?
For this example dv_1/dy was
zero, because v_1 is zero.
dv_2/dx was one,
because v_2 is x.
So there's some rotation here.
And in other words the
test for being a gradient
is no rotation.
This fails that test.
But how is it rotating?
How can it be rotating when
the all the flow is just
traveling vertically?
I guess I give you this example
because it meant something
to me.
My image of rotation was this
simpleminded type of flow.
You know, like a phonograph
record or something.
This would be
called a sheer flow.
A very important type of flow.
And actually, you'll realize
that if x is negative
then the flow in the second
component, the velocity,
is now negative.
So it would be the
streamline, the flow
would be going down this way.
And this point
wouldn't move at all.
This would be, well I don't
know if it's a streamline,
it's a stagnant
streamline, right? x=0.
On that line, there's
no velocity. [0, 0].
So this is all
just staying there.
These lines are moving,
this line moving faster,
this line would be
moving even faster.
This line's going the other way.
Faster and faster the other way.
It's a important flow.
You know, in earthquakes
and things like that.
This happens, when one plate
shears with respect to another.
So that's shearing.
The word shearing means
that a line that was --
that line after a
while is tilted.
This is going faster than this.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Right, being a constant.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
That's true.
Ah, well, OK.
Let's see.
Well, how do I fix that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yes.
That's a good question.
Should I have allowed
in my stream function,
I mean that's a stream function.
Because it satisfies the
equations that stream functions
are -- I could have thrown
in a constant, yeah.
So your pointing
out a difficulty
makes me think I should
have thrown in a constant.
So if I throw in constants then
I could get other lines, yeah.
Thanks, that's a good point.
I just want to see, do you
see rotation in this flow,
in this shear flow?
And I think you do.
If you think about it.
Suppose you put a little leaf,
or a little penny or something
right there.
OK, is it going to turn?
It'll flow along, but as it
flows, is it going to turn?
In other words, is there some
difference in the speed on one
side compared to the other?
I mean, it's what makes
a curveball curve, right?
When the pitcher throws the
ball, he imparts a spin to it,
and that gives a
different pressure
on the two sides of the
ball, and the ball moves.
I think that's going
to happen here.
Maybe you see it,
and I'm just talking.
I mean, this side is going
faster than this side.
So the net result is that even
though the thing is traveling
up and down, it's turning.
It's turning because the
right-hand side is going faster
than the left-hand side.
So it does have a rotation.
This quantity, this difference
between dv_1/dy and dv_2/dx,
which is the
component of the curl,
maybe the sign should
be the opposite,
maybe I think it should be minus
this plus this or something.
Point is that it's not zero.
So there is curl,
there is rotation.
OK.
I was going to ask
about this picture, too.
And then I'll open
to more examples.
I just feel examples are good.
Simple velocity fields, like 0x.
Just to think through,
OK, what does that mean?
Is it curl free?
Another way of saying is it a
gradient field would be to say
is it curl free?
Irrotational is the
right word here.
Test one, is it
irrotational, answer no.
Is it divergence-free,
is it source-free,
the answer was yes,
for this example.
If we pick another example
I could reverse those,
or another example -- I
can probably come up with
an example here.
Let's see, what if I wanted
the streamlines to be circles,
what would be a good velocity
field that goes in circles?
Let's see.
At a typical point, if I want
the velocity to be going that
way, here's the vector,
the position vector,
the radial vector that goes
-- so what are the components
of this vector?
Just [x, y].
So now if I want the velocity
field to go other way,
what would be a good
thing with rotation?
[-y, x] would sound good.
v=[-y, x].
So are we expecting this to
be a gradient of anything?
I'm not.
We've built in rotation here.
I'm expecting the curl of
this thing, this quantity,
I think I take the
x derivative --
I look at the y derivative of
this and compare it with the x
derivative of that.
And they're not the same;
in fact one is minus one
and the other's plus one.
So I've got rotation here.
I've got sort of two, is
the component of the curl.
So let's just write
it down. dv_2/dx,
this vorticity that measures
the turning speed is one from
dv_2/dx, minus one is two.
So it's not a
gradient of anything.
If the x derivative
of u is minus y,
then the y derivative
can't be plus x, no good.
OK, what about, is
it divergence-free?
Do I need a source to
keep this flow going?
Well, what's the test?
In other words, is there a
stream function for this guy?
I think probably there is.
What's the test to know if
there is a stream function?
I take the divergence, I'm
over on the right-hand side
of my picture now.
I take the divergence.
Divergence of this v is
the x derivative of that
plus the y derivative
of that, good, zero.
So there is a stream function.
And what is it?
Well, I'm pretty sure that
these streamlines are circles,
I think the stream
function is going
to be x squared plus y squared.
Yep.
Then, am I right that the y
derivative of that will be 2y.
That's not looking too good.
What do I want here?
Here's my v, which
is the same as w.
And what I'm looking for is
to get these guys correct.
So -- and I should
be able to do it.
And what would s be?
I haven't got s quite right.
I think if I multiply
by negative 1/2,
that might have done it.
Yeah, because now the y
derivative is now minus y.
Great.
And the x derivative
of s is minus x,
and then I should take
a minus that, so I
should want a plus x,
which is what I've got.
So those are the streamlines.
Circles.
So I have circle, the flow
is going around in a circle.
I don't have to -- I don't need
any source to keep it going.
But it's not a gradient.
So this is like a sample test,
to take a simple flow field,
apply the two tests,
and I guess we
should complete with an
example that passes both tests.
Right?
Let me open to any
other question,
and then we could cook
up an example that passes
both tests before we stop.
I'll stop talking first, though.
Just listen for a
question on any topic.
Or is it useful just to
take fields like this
and go through those steps?
It probably is.
It's certainly good for me.
OK, what's a field that
will satisfy everybody,
that will be a
gradient field and also
divergence-free, so that
we'll have solutions
to Laplace's equation.
Let's see.
Well we had some solutions
to Laplace's equation there.
You know if I make it
linear it's real easy.
If I make it quadratic -- huh.
Can I anticipate a little
what's coming Friday?
I so recommend to come to
Friday's lecture, but --
so what's coming?
What did we do today?
We discovered that we got
solutions to Laplace's equation
from all, by real and imaginary
parts of all these guys.
Those were terrific.
And then we could take
combinations of those.
So here's what's coming Friday.
When I take combinations of
these guys I get some function
of this magic complex -- of
this magic combination x+iy.
Some function, any function.
Any reasonable function, and
we'll say what reasonable
means, of x+iy, its real part
and its imaginary part are
going to be great.
This is like the center of a
big, big part of mathematics.
Functions of x+iy.
And by nice I mean that
these series converge.
So that we have really
a nice function.
Let me take the first function
that comes to mind. e^(x+iy).
So let me take this
to be e^(x+iy).
OK.
Right.
So you remember, I'm
aiming to get solutions
to Laplace's equation, because
that will give me automatically
the two pieces both working.
So I claim that the real part
of that, and the imaginary part,
those are my twins, u
and s, both solve --
so u is going to be the
real part of this function.
And s is going to be the
imaginary part of it.
And I claim that those will
both solve Laplace's equation.
We can plug it in
and see that it does.
And that they will
have, they're twinned
by the Cauchy-Riemann equations.
So how am I going
to simplify that,
so that I can identify what's
the real part of that thing
and what's the imaginary part?
This is actually,
that's a good question.
I don't know how much you've
run into i, in the past.
Are you happy with
something like that?
How could you find
the real part of it,
how could you simplify it?
How else could I write
e to the something?
Exactly.
Think of it as the
product of two,
so the key fact about
exponentials is that
that's the same as
e^x times e^(iy).
The exponents add, so that's
the first thing always
to think about as a possibility.
Now, what am I going to do?
I still want to get a real part.
This is clearly all
real, right? e^x is real.
So it's this part that's going
to give me the two pieces.
So this is going to
be e^x times -- now,
what do I put for e^(iy)?
cos(y), good.
Plus i*sin(y), good.
And now I can read
off, no problem.
What is this real part that I
was looking for? e^x*cos(y).
And the imaginary part is
just what's multiplying the i,
it's the e^x*sin(y).
OK, so what's my claim?
I claim that that function
solves Laplace's equation.
And this one too.
And that they're twinned.
And that they give
streamlines and equipotentials
that meet at right
angles, it's another pair.
Plug that into
Laplace's equation.
So let me do u_xx+u_yy, just
to satisfy that it is going
to come out zero.
So what's the xx derivative,
the second x derivative
of that function?
Take its derivative with respect
to x, and then do it again,
and what do you have?
Same.
Didn't change. e^x is just --
and now what about the second y
derivative?
So now e^x is just a constant.
What's the second
derivative of cos(y)?
Negative cos(y).
Right.
Because the first
derivative is negative sine,
the second derivative
is negative cosine.
So the second derivative
is e^x, it didn't change,
times cos(y) with a minus sine.
And you see what --
did I write sine?
I meant to write cosine.
Cancel that from the tape.
OK, right.
Yeah.
So the second x derivative
was just e^x, e^x,
cos(y) didn't move.
Sorry.
That was frightening.
OK, and then now here's
the second y derivative.
In other words, it gives zero.
Gives zero, and
this one would too.
Now, I don't really have an idea
of what the picture is like.
But it's important.
We've got a flow field here,
and it's from e^z, e^(x+iy).
Exponential has gotta be
an important function.
So it's got to be
somehow interesting.
What do you think --
so what would the --
what would the equipotential
lines looks like?
Oh, boy.
e^x*cos(y) equal a constant.
My gosh.
e^x*cos(y).
So let's see.
I don't know how to draw this
picture, but one thing I know
is that if I changed y by
2pi, I would get another copy
of this curve, right?
If I changed y by -- every
time you see cosine or sine,
you think hey, that's periodic.
If I change it by 2pi.
So I'm thinking that y between
zero and 2 pi, so here's y=0.
And y=2pi, I'm thinking that
my flow probably somehow stays
in a strip.
Like that.
And then the whole thing
just repeats, and repeats,
and repeats.
So I'm thinking, really this
is flow in an infinite strip.
Infinite pipe or
something like that.
You can imagine that there
could be applications.
But I still haven't
drawn the curve.
I just think, let's see, what
would it look like when y is
a little -- suppose I'm
trying to draw the picture
of e^x*cos(y)=1, whatever.
OK, I'll just attempt
to draw that curve.
Just, so if y was a
little bit off of zero,
the cosine would be, yeah,
how's it going to go?
If y is just a little
off zero, tell me
any points on this curve?
I can see that e^x is
going to be a big number.
Is (0,0) on the curve?
Good.
Got one point.
Alright.
Now, suppose y is a
little bit more than zero.
So suppose y goes
up a little bit.
Then what? (1,0) or something?
Yeah.
I suppose (1,0)?
No, no.
So if y goes up a little, then
x would go out a little bit.
So what's happening?
So cos(y), so the cos(y) is
going to drop from one to zero,
right?
To start with.
Then, if this cos(y) is dropping
from one to zero then this e^x
has got to climb up, to
to keep the product one.
So I'll move out.
So somehow it'll move out.
I think maybe when
y reaches pi/2,
then the cosine has
got down to zero.
We could work on
this for a while.
Or we could let MATLAB draw it.
But I think that we would see
these -- and I could do better.
I'm feeling pretty humiliated to
not have a better picture here.
Suppose y is a little
less than zero,
do we get anything
interesting there?
Oh well, the cosine
is an even function.
So I think the thing
might, is it just
going to turn around like that?
So that y and minus
y -- for a certain x,
the y value and the minus
y will both be on the curve
because the cosine doesn't
know whether it's the cosine
of of a plus or a minus.
Yeah, I think we would
get curves of that sort.
And then the other
curves, s equal constant,
the streamlines will
somehow go vertically.
Maybe I'll just not
use the whole time
to work on that
particular curve.
We'd have to prepare it.
The point is, you see how
incredibly easily we produce
solutions to Laplace's
equation that you
wouldn't have thought of, and
I wouldn't have thought of.
So that would be one way
to produce solutions.
I might even repeat this one in
class Friday, or I might not.
Let me suggest another
couple of possibilities
that I will do in class.
Can I just give you a
couple of other functions f.
In fact, I'll just erase that
one and put in some other ones.
Suppose I took the
function 1/(x+iy).
So that's a function of this
magic combination, x+iy.
What's its real part and
what's its imaginary part?
Do you know how to split that
guy into real and imaginary?
There's a little
trick, if you remember
from learning complex numbers.
Do you remember the trick?
The problem is that this thing
is down in the denominator,
right?
We don't want it there.
Because we can't split the real
and imaginary parts down there.
So I would like to
rewrite it in a way that
gets something real
down in the denominator,
moves all the i stuff
up in the numerator
where I can separate it.
How do I do it?
Multiply both sides by, both
top and bottom, by x-iy.
Good.
So what does that
put down here now?
That's a number
times its conjugate
and that's going to
produce x squared.
Minus or plus?
Plus y squared, right.
The number times its conjugate
is the length squared.
And now we just have x-iy, and
now it's obvious what the u is.
This is real now,
so the u is just
x over x squared plus
y squared, and the s
is the minus y over x
squared plus y squared.
That's a very interesting flow.
That's an interesting
flow, and we
could do its picture and so on.
And in fact it would
be a nicer picture
than the one we stopped on.
What should I notice
about this flow?
Of course, the flow is
automatically irrotational;
the curl is zero because
there is a potential.
A gradient of a potential,
the gradient of a potential
is going to be free of rotation.
And there will be streamlines,
all those good things.
There's one bad point
about the flow, though.
Which is where?
At (0,0).
The whole thing falls apart,
at the origin this falls apart.
So this is a great flow
except at the origin,
it's very problematic.
It's singular at the origin.
So if we drew the pictures we
would see something strange.
This is going to
zero at the origin.
So, yeah, we have trouble at
the origin but an important flow
otherwise, yep.
And I'll just mention
the third but I
won't do anything with it.
Because it's such
a neat one that I
have to save it for Friday.
The other natural function
to think of is the logarithm.
The logarithm of x+iy.
Split that into u and s.
What kind of a thing
do we have here?
What kind of singularity?
Yeah, let me just do two
moments on this example,
and then leave it for Friday
because the whole class has
to see it.
Is there a singularity
for this guy?
Is there a point (x,y) where
the logarithm is not great?
At the origin, again.
We'll again have a
singularity at the origin.
Something strange is
happening at the origin.
And what we'll find is there's
a delta function there.
We're feeding in, we have a
source right at the origin
and then it's flowing out
on, I think on radial lines.
I think the streamlines
go out from the origin
and the equipotentials
go around the origin.
Yeah, it's a great example.
So that's another one to come.
OK, so examples
like these are --
I mean generations of
thinking went into solutions
of Laplace's equation.
And 2-D particularly where we
have this special combination.
I wish we had such a combination
in 3-D but we simply don't.
We can discuss Laplace's
equation in 3-D of course,
very important.
But I mean, wave equation, this
fact that we're talking to each
other, is got the Laplacian in
3-D, but there's no x+iy magic.
OK, that's some u's and
s's and v's and w's.
What else is on your mind?
Questions?
I could ask this question,
oh, here's something
I did not do in class.
I think I wrote down
the divergence theorem.
So can we start by doing that?
Let me write down the divergence
theorem, with your help.
And then use it.
So what does the divergence
theorem -- we're in 2-D.
So this is 2-D, just
the similar theorem.
So what does the theorem say,
that if I take the divergence
of some w, some vector field,
then if I integrate that over
some region -- so I have some
region here and at every point
there's a flow w.
And I look at the divergence of
w and I integrate that, dx dy,
so that's a double
integral over a region,
I will get, what's
the right-hand side?
What does the
divergence measure?
So I'm really asking like just
memory, what is the divergence,
it's an identity.
It's integration by parts
in some way, as we'll see.
But what do you remember
for the divergence theorem?
You get what?
It measures how much
flux out, right?
So when we measure the
flux out by integrating
around the boundary, how much
is getting through the boundary?
And what's the flow
through the boundary?
I take w, but that's a vector.
And I'm looking for
what component of w?
The normal component, the
component of w, w dot n,
the component of w that's
headed out. n is defined to be,
whatever the boundary is -- here
I've made it look like a circle
but I shouldn't have.
Let me make it a little
wobblier or something.
So the normal component at
any, there, look at that point.
The normal direction
through the boundary,
down in that crazy
point, is this way.
So the normal is
going this way here.
Here, it's going over this way.
It's perpendicular
to the boundary, OK?
And then we integrate
around the boundary.
Alright.
So that's the identity of that,
that's the divergence theorem.
Now, let's see.
Could you, yeah.
So we have a minute.
You want to take a
particular w and see
if this would be correct?
How about w=w=[0, x],
our first example?
Suppose I tried w=[0, x].
I just want to see
if the divergence --
what the flux is
through the boundary.
What what region shall
I take for the --
so the divergence
theorem has two inputs.
It has a flow field.
And let me take w to be
[0, x], just so it's a shear.
And a region.
And of course the integral might
not be that much fun to do,
unless we make the region nice.
What do you take as a nice
region for -- actually,
it doesn't matter
what the region is.
Take any old region.
For the moment.
What's the answer?
For this particular
flow, w=w=[0, x]?
Zero.
That's the cool part.
If the answer's zero
then work is suspended.
And why is it zero?
Because the divergence
of this particular w,
the x derivative of that plus
the y derivative of that,
is zero.
This has divergence
everywhere zero.
So integrating is
no problem at all,
so that would be zero,
for this flow field.
For this divergence-free field.
Zero for that because
div w is zero.
But is that correct?
What does that tell
me, these flows are --
we saw what the flow is like.
Say there's the origin.
It doesn't have to be a
circle, it looks like a circle.
Do you see why the flux is zero?
There is flow through
the boundary, right?
Flow is going buzz, buzz,
buzz up this line and out.
And it's coming in here.
So there that's
what we discovered.
This [0, x] is vertical flow.
It hasn't gotten any
horizontal component.
It's got a vertical
component, it's going out.
And would we want to do
this right-hand side?
I don't think so, right.
This right-hand
side is asking me
what, I have to find the normal
direction on this, whatever
curve that is.
I have to take its dot
product with the flow [0, x],
so this is some quantity.
And then I have to do this ds
which I haven't even mentioned,
ds is arc length around.
I'm integrating
around these pieces.
But yet somehow we have
some idea from that picture
that the total flux is zero.
How would you say it in words,
if I say here's the flow field.
There's a region, funny shape.
The flux is zero
through that boundary.
And if I asked you why,
what would you say?
I mean, a math answer would
be use the divergence theorem.
But why from this picture does
it look like we have zero flux?
What comes in goes out, yeah.
What's coming in the bottom
here is going out the top.
That's basically it.
So we would get
zero for that one.
So I think the homework,
the suggested homework
maybe includes an example where
the divergence isn't zero.
And then you actually have
to do these integrals.
Just as practice for what
do those integrals mean.
Maybe I won't go through one
now, but that's good practice.
Take some simple w, but one
with a non-zero divergence
and then see if you
can do either or both
of the integrals that are
supposed to come out equal.
That's a good one Now,
there's one thing I could --
any questions, or discussion?
You guys are seeing
these examples come up;
it's the only way I would know
to learn this subject is take
simple v's and w's.
And see what you
can do with them.
We've got the
general principles,
but then apply them
to specific flows.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yes, thanks
PROFESSOR STRANG: This theorem?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Yeah if it was,
well let's draw a funny shape.
See what we think.
I mean, with this flow, right?
Let me just say, if the flow
has some difficult divergence
and the region is
some mess, nobody's
going to be able to do it.
I mean, yeah.
So don't think that
these can all be done.
The equality, it's like
integrals in calculus.
No problem to think
of integrations that
are just beyond human capacity.
But the formulas still hold.
Suppose my region
was even like this?
Would that still be, do we still
see flow in equals flow out
for this particular flow?
I think, yeah, the
flow's going this way.
So it's coming in here,
it's going out again.
That contributes.
Back in again here,
and out again here.
Yeah, I think our instinct
would be correct there, yeah.
All sorts of examples.
I was going to, well,
I'll maybe do it in class.
This divergence theorem
is the fundamental theorem
of 2-D calculus, you could say.
Or one of them.
And to write these things and
see what they lead to, yeah.
I'll tell you what
I was going to do.
I was going to apply this to
the vector field u times w.
So u is a scalar, w is a vector,
and therefore uw is a vector.
It's got two components, uw_1,
are you willing to do that one?
So I apply this not to w
itself, but to u times w.
Which has two components,
uw_1 and uw_2.
OK, so I should take
the divergence of uw.
I mean, that's a vector
field, uw, this guy.
And I'll get the uw dot n.
And it just turns out that
this is the right way to do it.
To see the fact that
gradient and divergence
are transposes of each other.
Yeah, yeah.
I maybe I won't do
that calculation now,
I'll just say that if you take
the divergence theorem and you
apply it to this
guy, [uw 1, uw 2],
and write out what it means, you
get a very interesting formula.
I'll just leave that there.
So I'm ready for a final
question if there is one,
or otherwise keep going Friday
with these Laplace equation
solutions.
Play with some vector fields.
That's my best advice.
And I'll see you Friday.